gdx es una transformación de fx aquí
tenemos a gx que es una línea roja
punteada y esta de aquí es fx que es una
línea sólida azul y nos preguntan cuál
es la fórmula de gdx en términos de fx y
como siempre por la pausa de este vídeo
e intentar resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno pues como observamos estas dos
gráficas aquí parece como que la gráfica
de g es una versión un poco más flaca de
la gráfica de f
parece como si estuviera comprimido
hacia el centro pero vamos a ver esto de
una forma más precisa vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar puntos
correspondientes así es que por ejemplo
si nos fijamos en f de -6 osea en este
punto de aquí parece como que
corresponde a ver vamos a poner esta
línea a ver cuál es el punto
correspondiente en la gráfica de g
estamos por aquí en la función f tenemos
este punto mínimo y luego estamos
volviendo a subir y llegamos a ésta
y parece como que el punto
correspondiente en la gráfica de g es
este de aquí que es g de menos 3 parece
como que f de menos 6 es igual a g de
menos 3 y estos sí son puntos
correspondientes pero bueno vamos a
hacer esto con otros puntos si nos
fijamos en f2 parece como que
corresponde a g de uno
efe de dos corresponde a g de uno y lo
vamos a escribir por aquí
efe de dos parece como que corresponde a
g de uno y lo que estoy haciendo es
fijándome en donde estas dos funciones
toman los mismos valores y bueno también
fijándome en que sea la misma parte de
la función suponiendo que la función g
es una versión comprimida de la función
efe pero bueno observando esto parece
como que la función efe
en cierta x va a ser igual
de bueno pues cualquier cosa que tenemos
aquí parece como que corresponde a tener
aquí la mitad de ese valor entonces
vamos a poner g de x sobre 2 o bueno si
quieres verlo de otra forma si queremos
poner por aquí a g de x pues vamos a
tener kg de x es igual a efe de y bueno
aquí sin importar lo que tengamos parece
que corresponde a efe de el doble de eso
entonces vamos a poner por aquí
efe de 2x y podemos ver por aquí que
está si es una de las opciones al
parecer cualquier valor que pongamos
aquí como el x si evaluamos que de x eso
es igual a tomar la f y evaluarla en 2
por ese valor de x estos dos valores que
tenemos por aquí lo confirmen y también
lo podemos ver aquí en esta gráfica
tomamos a la f la encogemos y nos queda
gdx y bueno otra forma de pensar en esto
cuando estamos multiplicando a la
entrada por algún número mayor a 1 esto
lo que va a hacer es comprimir a la
gráfica va a hacer que las cosas sucedan
mucho más rápido como la entrada de la
función va a aumentar mucho más rápido y
también se va a volver más negativa más
rápido aumenta la velocidad con la que
suceden las cosas y entonces se ve como
que la en cogemos y bueno si todavía no
te convence este argumento intenta
evaluar esta función en algunos puntos y
encuentra por aquí algunos otros puntos
donde la función f toma el mismo valor
que la función g y vas a ver una y otra
vez que para obtener el mismo valor vas
a tener que poner en la entrada de f el
doble que en la entrada de g bueno
espero que esto te haya servido